The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today I want to
make some remarks about
William Barton Rogers.
You were supposed to read an
essay that I wrote about him,
so I'm not going to go
into great detail.
I don't want to repeat what I've
already written in the
essay, but I thought I would hit
had some high points and
then end up talking a bit about
this piece that Charles
Eliot wrote called "The New
Education," because I readily
admit that that is not the
easiest thing to read and
surely not scintillating
prose--
you would not want to keep it up
with you at night and think
you're going to read
it one AM.
That wouldn't work.
But it's an important essay.
So we'll talk a bit about
that after I make
my few remarks here.
First thing I want to say is
that it's hard to believe that
MIT has no full-scale
history--
history book, that is, a book
that's been written about the
entire history of MIT.
One does not exist.
As close as we get to it is the
book you're reading now.
And basically that consists
primarily of snapshots of
critical moments in the
institute's history.
I think it's a very good book,
but it's not a complete
history of the Institute.
And hopefully, someday, someone
will decide one is
needed and actually write it.
It will take it a lot of work
because the more I read and
study about this place, the more
I realize that it has a
very deep and very
diverse history.
And it will not be an easy book
to write, in my opinion--
or at least to make it
a good book, that it
really should be.
But all the great universities
in the United States have
these histories and MIT is one
of the few that doesn't.
And I was sort of surprised
at that.
I must admit, I didn't know a
thing about the history of MIT
until about two or three years
ago, when I was asked to write
this essay, and then, all of
the sudden, I, of course,
started to read as much as I
could about it in preparing
for the essay that I wrote.
But I was really surprised that
there's no one big book
you can go to and kind of
get the story there.
My assignment by the editor of
the book Moments of Decision,
his name is David Kaiser, and he
teaches in the STS program,
history of physics.
He's also a physicist.
He has a Ph.D in physics.
And he persuaded me to write
this essay, which I did
because he was my colleague,
not because I wanted to, I
must admit.
But I'm glad I did in retrospect
because I learned a
lot about this place
and especially
about its early years.
And so what that in mind, I want
to talk about, well, what
did I learn from this extensive
reading that I did,
and what did I learn especially
about William
Barton Rogers the person and the
significance of his life?
I think it's fair to say from
the outset that he is a very
significant educator.
In the larger history of
education, he has to be one of
the more important people
of the 19th century.
He came of age in the middle
of America's Industrial
Revolution.
He was born in 1804, so he was
in his 20s during the 1820s,
right at the very moment when
the United States was really
beginning to experience
factory systems, the
mechanization of production,
the advent of railroads--
it was the moment.
It was the right moment to be
in the country, to see these
changes taking place.
And he saw them, and he was
very, very interested in them,
though he always considered
himself to be a scientist.
He was initially educated by
his father, primarily, at
William and Mary.
His father was an academician.
And he initially called himself
a natural philosopher,
which would be a 19th
century word for
a physicist, basically.
Natural philosophy--
interesting name.
But technology in those days,
interestingly, was also
referred to as "the useful
arts." The word technology, in
the 1820s, I don't even know
if it had appeared in the
United States at that point.
But in any case, it was a very
new word to the lexicon and it
was rarely used until we had
the founding of this place,
the Massachusetts Institute
of Technology.
It's very interesting that
he chose that word.
If I could go back and interview
Rogers, that would
be one of the questions I'd want
to ask him, is why did
you choose the word technology,
not Massachusetts
Institute of Useful Arts, or
some more contemporary
expression that was used,
frankly, more often than the
word technology was, by 1860.
In any cases here he is.
He's a young man during
the 1820s.
His first job out of college
was to teach in a small
private school in Baltimore
Maryland.
And it's in Baltimore that he
comes in contact with some of
the really famous railroad
engineers of
the early 19th century.
All of these guys were West
Point-trained people.
They were army engineers who had
been basically seconded to
the Baltimore and Ohio
Railroad, a private
corporation, to initiate surveys
and construction of
this privately owned railroad.
Talk about government in.
It's a great example, in which,
here, the federal
government is actually sending
its own personnel to a private
corporation to get
the job started.
And so he meets people like
William Gibbs McNeill and
George Washington Whistler,
who, actually,
are brothers in law.
Whistler is the more interesting
of-- well, more
historically interesting
of the two.
They're both important engineers
because his son
became a very famous artist,
James McNeill Abbott Whistler,
is George Washington's son.
And the famous portrait,
Whistler's mother, that sits
in the Louvre in Paris is of
George Washington's wife, who
was a McNeill as a young lady.
So here you have these engineers
in Baltimore
interacting with this young
teacher because he got
interested in railroads and
wanted to give a lecture about
the building of this new steam
powered railroad out of
Baltimore westward toward
the Ohio River.
And he started borrowing models
from these engineers to
illustrate his lectures with.
They were building very
interesting and fairly, not
large scale models--
but I've seen some of them,
they currently exist in
Russia, they're found in a
museum in St. Petersburg--
of the type of bridges that were
being built on the B&O
railroad, and the types of
locomotives and rolling stock.
A locomotive would be maybe that
long, a 440, that wide,
it's this high, fairly
sizable model.
But he was borrowing these
models to give lectures with
and, in the process, began to
get interested in railroads,
and especially because his
brothers, two of his brothers,
actually worked for McNeill.
Once they left the B&O, McNeill
came north to the
Boston area to build a railroad
that, basically, is
now part of the Northeast
corridor.
It's the road between Boston
and Providence--
and did the surveys on that,
even those these two young
were basically interested in
geology, McNeill hired them to
help with the survey team,
and then, on the side, he
encouraged them to do geological
explorations of the
area, which they did.
And they loved it.
And they got to really admire
these army engineers, so much
so that they really seriously
thought about becoming
engineers themselves.
That didn't happen, primarily
because they felt that army
engineers had such an inroad
into the engineering business
at that time, they were really
the only serious engineers in
the United States, were these
West Point trained people,
that they didn't think they had
much of a chance getting
the good jobs compared to what
Whistler, and McNeill, and
others were getting as a result
of their connection
with the Army.
Both Whistler and McNeill left
the Army in the 1830s and
became private, consulting
engineers.
And Whistler went on to engineer
not only the Western
branch of what became the Boston
and Albany railroad,
which was the first major
railroad to go over a serious
mountain chain, the Berkshire
mountains.
If you drive west on the Mass
Pike and go up over the
Berkshires toward Albany, New
York, you're going exactly
through the area that Whistler
ran a railroad through during
the mid 1830s, late 1830s--
serious elevations there.
And he did it.
He got a lot of attention
for doing it.
And one of the groups that paid
attention to him were
these Russian engineers that
were sent to the United States
by Tsar, I think
it's Nicholas.
It's either Nicholas or
Alexander, but, in
any case, he was--
DAVID KAISER: Weren't they all
Nicholas or Alexander?
PROFESSOR: Nicholas and
Alexander, you've got to be
one or the other.
I can't be far wrong
on that one.
But in any case, he was hired by
the tsar to go to Russia to
engineer what is now called the
Moscow and St. Petersburg
Railroad, which he did.
He died in Russia, of
cholera, in 1849.
But his body was brought back
to the United States and
buried down in Stonington,
Connecticut.
I have visited his grave.
And I can attest that George
Washington Whistler now lies
in Stonington, Connecticut.
But he was a great engineer, and
he was an important here.
He had a lot of influence on
Rogers and his brothers.
And as a result of that, as I
said, they both contemplated
engineering careers but then
backed away and decided, no,
we are really educators.
We're interested in this new
field called geology.
Both William Barton and his
brother Henry Darwin Rogers
became very, very eminent
geologists.
In fact, Henry, his younger
brother, actually got an
appointment at the University
of Glasgow as a chaired
professor there during the--
I think it was during the
late 1840s, early 1850s.
And it's in the process of
experiencing these things with
these new railroads and
industrial ventures that
really begins to turn his head
toward these "useful arts" and
to think about how are they
related to the sorts of
scientific interests
that he has.
The other experience that he had
that's very important in
all this was that when he was
teaching at the University of
Virginia in the 1830s he was
appointed the head of the
state Geological Survey, and
I've written about that in the
essay, in which she had a
miserable time because of the
political interest that were
vying with one another.
He conducted the survey.
He completed it, but the results
of the survey, which
were important, were never
published because the
legislature was bickering
among themselves--
sounds familiar--
about the costs, whether it was
a worthwhile project, the
whole thing you might imagine.
But in any case, Rogers was
disgusted with Virginia.
Surely, by the late '40s, he was
really disgusted with the
whole state legislature and
political process there.
But in conducting these surveys
from one end of the
state to the other, and in those
days, Virginia included
the current state of West
Virginia, not just the current
state of Virginia.
It was a big state.
He got interested, basically,
in things like mountain
formations and very much
interested in where mineral
deposits were located and
things like that.
But the big problem was finding
assistants that could
help him conduct the sort of
geological work that he needed
to do in order to finish up the
survey and make a report.
And that was another stimulus
toward his interest in trying
to do something with combining
science with the useful arts.
So those are, I would say, two
critical moments during the
1830s in which he really began
to begin to think about
establishing some sort of what
we would call a Polytechnic
Institute, or Institute
of Technology.
He and his brother both started
talking about this as
early as 1829 in Baltimore.
But then it got continued
throughout the 1830s and well
into the 1840s.
And that's really how the whole
idea of what this place
is about got started.
Rogers also saw, through these
years, that there was a crying
need for people to do
engineering work and meet what
he referred to as the "wants
of the age." This was the
great field, the open field--
lots of jobs and possibilities
for advancement.
And he saw that, and,
again, it stimulated
his interest in education.
So as a result of this, he
develops a plan for a
Polytechnic Institute, the first
draft of which, I think,
was written as early as 1829.
And then over the next 30 years
he and his brother sort
of elaborate on this plan
about how would
they organize it?
What disciplines would
be included?
But the key, I think, the key
idea that they developed over
these years was trying to
combine, trying to develop an
educational system that would
combine science with the
useful arts, make them relevant
to one another and
especially inform the useful
arts about what science could
reveal to them-- the
understandings of chemistry,
or physics, or whatever.
And of courses, as you've read,
the finality of this
comes in 1861, when he receives
a charter from the
state of Massachusetts to
establish what is called the
Massachusetts Institute
of Technology.
Now in that, he'd had to
do a lot of lobbying.
He had learned how to work with
politicians through that
miserable Virginia experience.
I think it made him
a wiser man--
maybe a cagier person in terms
of learning how to work with
politicians or to get
around the obstacles
they put in this way.
It's during the early questions
about the charter
for MIT, for example, that the
governor of Massachusetts, who
was a Harvard graduate, first
proposed the idea of, why
create this MIT as a
separate institute?
Why not combine it
with Harvard?
It's one of those early
questions about, well, why not
combine it with Harvard rather
than make it a separate
institution?
Rogers resisted that throughout
this entire life.
And there were several other
attempts made during his
lifetime to try to merge
MIT with Harvard.
But it began very early.
And it began first with the
government of Massachusetts,
who would like to have
seen that sort of
combination put together.
But once they got the charter,
the big challenge then was to
try to get the place going.
And the problem was that he got
his charter in April 1861,
and what happens in
1861, in April?
Civil War.
And so a war breaks out.
It makes it difficult for him
to raise money, basically--
very difficult to raise money.
And some scholars who have
studied the history of MIT
think that maybe it was a good
thing that there was a war, in
terms of his interest, because
it gave him time to complete
this plans and to work the
political process in a way
that allowed him to
eventually get the
Institute started in 1865.
There may be some truth to that,
but I think the real
problem that he faced
1861 was money.
And that was a problem MIT was
going to face for the next
four years or so.
MIT was always running in the
red, basically, well into the
late 1890s and probably
beyond that.
I just haven't studied that
much beyond the fiscal
situation beyond the 1890s.
But in any case, he
got his charter.
He has to hire faculty.
He has to choose and acquire a
site to initiate classes in.
He has to raise this money.
There are a lot of things that
have to be accomplished.
And I think one of the big
godsends of the period was
that there was a law
passed in 1862.
It was a federal law, part of
the Lincoln administration's
political agenda called the
Morrill Land Grant Act.
And I remember reading about
this when I was your age and
being totally bored by it.
But it turns out that that is
a very important piece of
legislation because it led to
the establishment of what we
call the land grant university
system in this country.
All the big state universities,
basically, are
related to that land
grant act.
Some very directly, and others
less so, but, nonetheless,
most of them--
Texas A&M, Penn State, Ohio
State, Michigan State,
Wisconsin, Berkeley, you know,
you can go across the country
and almost choose.
In every state, there's at least
one institution that was
founded under the Morrill Act.
Well, that Morrill Act
was passed in 1862.
And basically, what it said
was that for each
congressional representative
that you had in the US
Congress, the state would get
30,000 acres of land, which it
in turn could convert into
script and sell the script, or
the rights to the land, as
a way of raising money to
establish agricultural
mechanical colleges within the
state boundaries--
A&Ms, if you want to
call them that.
So Massachusetts, I think,
had 10 congressional
representatives and
two US Senators.
So it got a fairly sizable chunk
of land in the Midwest.
If I'm not mistaken, it was out
in the area of northern
Iowa, southern Minnesota, in
that area, where a lot of this
land was located.
People in Minnesota and Iowa,
by the way, were not happy
that the federal government was
giving away land in their
states to states that had
nothing to do with them.
You can imagine how people in
Minnesota must've felt about
this huge chunk of land going
to New York State, or
Massachusetts, or wherever.
But in any case, that converted
into substantial
funds that were used to found
not only MIT but also the
University of Massachusetts
at Amherst.
And basically, MIT got a
third of those monies
over a 30 year period.
It was given to them
in increments.
They got a sizable amount of
money, well over $300,000.
That may not sound like much
today, but if you convert it
into 2008 dollars, it's
a big hunk of money.
I don't know but I've--
DAVID KAISER: Well, it would
put you through MIT today.
PROFESSOR: It would put
you through MIT today.
That's a good way to put it.
Yeah, so it's a sizable
amount of money.
DAVID KAISER: Plus a
couple vacations.
PROFESSOR: But probably just as
important as the grant from
the state itself, which
consisted not only of money,
but also of land, over
in the Back Bay--
MIT was first established not
here, where we are today, but
over in the Back Bay
near Copley Square.
If you're familiar with that
area, the original building
was very close, block or two,
from Copley Square.
And it stayed there until
1916, pretty much.
But in any case, the money for
all that came from the state
of Massachusetts.
So the state was important
in all this.
Without the state, I would, in
fact, question whether private
donors would have stepped
forward to donate money to MIT
because they weren't sure
about its future.
But when the state began to
invest in MIT, that sort of
gave a signal that, yeah,
MIT's got a future.
I'm going to pony up some money
and give --and one of
the big donations that came very
soon after MIT got the
state funds was a donation that
I begin my essay with,
this doctor--
what's his name--
DAVID KAISER: Walker?
PROFESSOR: What is it?
DAVID KAISER: Walker.
PROFESSOR: Walker, yes.
William Walker, a physician who
had invested in industry
in this state.
This was a leading
industrial state.
And he ponied up $60,000--
a lot of money for a private
individual in those days.
DAVID KAISER: On the last
day before the--
PROFESSOR: In the last day,
yeah, so it was an iffy
proposition from
the beginning.
And Rogers, I think one of his
great skills was as a, in a
way, small p politician,
a lobbyist.
He was very effective at
lobbying people, and raising
funds, and keeping this
institution going from one
year, literally, one
year to another.
Because every year, as I said,
it was running on the red.
But he made it go.
DAVID KAISER: Something about
Back Bay, too-- because maybe
not everybody knows that
what is now Back
Bay was once a Bay.
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
DAVID KAISER: And I hadn't
really remembered until I was
reading the reading last night
that part of the initial
interest was--
they filled in the Back Bay to
make what is now Back Bay,
which was a huge engineering
project in and of itself.
And then there was interest
in using that land for
educational purposes, which
Rogers then sort of satisfied
to some degree.
PROFESSOR: Right.
And I think I mentioned in the
essay that the initial
proposal was not just for an
industrial school, MIT, but
was also for a natural history
museum and a society of arts.
It was a 3 part combination that
was initially proposed.
And eventually, of course,
MIT was the
one that really lasted.
And the other two sort of
slipped by the wayside.
But in any case, that's the
story of the beginning
because, I think, in the early
days, if I'm not mistaken,
that one of the early courses
at MIT was in mining and,
what's the other--
DAVID KAISER: Metallurgy.
PROFESSOR: Mining
and metallurgy.
And in those days, geology
would've been
lumped into that area.
And then later, it becomes--
yeah, yeah.
Now, I can't absolutely
swear that's the
case, but that's my--
what would say say, an
educated guess, I
guess, would be.
So to look at Rogers and just
say, OK, what are some of the
important points to remember
about him?
One is, he's a good lobbyist.
He keeps the place going.
He keeps the vision alive, OK?
And secondly, there's
the vision itself.
You see it on the great
seal of MIT.
You know, interestingly, if
you look at the seal, it's
interesting.
It says mens et manus--
mind and hand.
Science and the useful arts,
another way to think of it.
But clearly, that vision of the
combination of science and
the useful arts was there
from day one.
And that seal was actually
approved in 1864, if I'm not
mistaken Rogers was on the
committee that, you know,
approved that seal.
And he obviously played a role,
I mean, I think his
vision is sort of stamped,
literally, into the seal
itself, of what this place
was going to be.
One curious thing about that
seal, however, I'll
point it out now.
It's not original with me, but
a colleague of mine, years
ago, pointed it out to me,
and I have thought
about it ever since--
was that when you look at this
seal, you have a craftsman, or
an industrial worker, and a
scholar, OK, the scientist and
the useful arts standing next
to a pedestal, and then the
words mens et manus below,
and the date of
the founding of MIT.
The interesting thing though is
that, in Rogers' vision he
wanted to combine, he wanted
each of them, science and
useful arts, to inform
one another.
That was the special thing,
the idea that he had.
This was a new way of
educating people.
And yet these figures, science
and engineering, or science
and useful arts, they have their
backs turned to each
other, as if they're not
conversing at all.
Curious.
I don't know it if was for
aesthetic purposes or what,
but from a didactic point of
view, they should have been
facing each other, and having
discussions, and interacting.
Clearly, they're not
doing anything.
They're sort of both in
their own worlds.
And that's an interesting
comment, I think, just on the
seal, not necessarily about
Rogers' vision.
But he has this important idea
about the combination of the
two, which is very important.
And in the essay, I put a lot of
emphasis on the importance
of laboratory education there,
in which students are not just
being given lectures and
demonstrations by the
professor using the apparatus,
but, in fact, they're allowed
to go in and perform experiments
themselves using
the apparatus.
One of the reasons why MIT was
constantly in financial
difficulty was the need to
maintain the laboratories that
were so critical to the
education of its students.
Laboratories are very expensive,
to this day
probably the most expensive
item in the MIT budget, I
would think-- one of the
most expensive ones.
Look around us at these new
buildings that are going up
just in the biological sciences
and think of the
expense that has been
invested in them.
And it was no less true
in the 19th century.
And it had a special meaning for
Rogers because he wanted
students to be immersed in that
experimental process and
not just lookers-on.
He wanted them involved
in the process.
And I think that's one of the
really distinctive things
about MIT, then and today.
I keep thinking that vision of
1861, 1864, of Rogers can be
seen in the UROP projects.
And several of you have written
in your reflections
about this today--
different programs that exist at
MIT that have that sort of
active involvement of students
that, in the days of the
1860s, just didn't exist at
other places, or surely not to
any extent like it did at MIT.
The other thing that Rogers
had was an eye for talent.
Every great leader needs to
surround themselves with
capable people.
And the more capable,
the better.
And Rogers, I don't know if
you want to call it good
fortune or just the ability to
spot people and hire them.
But he hired a very
talented staff.
I think there were something
like 20 professors, maybe not
even 20, by 1870, five years
after classes started.
But at least half of them were
very, very competent people.
And two of the most important
were a guy named Francis
Storer, S-T-O-R-E-R, and
somewhat younger guy, but not
a lot younger, Charles Eliot,
both of whom were chemists,
both of whom were Harvard
educated, and, it turns out,
both of whom were
brothers in law.
Storer married Eliot's sister.
And Storer came to MIT first.
He was one of the first faculty
hired at MIT, to set
up a chemistry department
here.
And then Eliot, who was studying
in Germany, was hired
like in 1867 to come in and
fill out that enterprise.
And they end up building
one of the first really
experimental research oriented
laboratories in the United
States, academic, anyway.
And they also are the first to
write textbooks for the study
of chemistry, and chemical
experiments, and things like--
two very famous textbooks that
were published during the
early, well, the late 1860s
and early 1870s.
So they're important people.
Now the interesting thing is
that Eliot was at MIT a very
short period of time.
He came and '67 and he
left in '69 to become
President of Harvard.
And interestingly, it's Eliot
who really initiates all these
attempts to merge Harvard
with MIT.
The essay that you read today
called, "The New Education,"
same guy, Charles Eliot, the
author is Charles Eliot.
He wrote that while he was at
MIT, but the same year that
essay was published, he becomes
president of Harvard.
And immediately, he starts
making overtures to William
Rogers about, come
on, Bill, let's--
I don't know if they'd
call him Bill.
I've often wondered, what did
they call William-- did
William Rogers have
a nickname?
We had a reunion over in
Burton-Conner about two or
three weeks ago, and they
had this big cut
out picture of Rogers.
And one of the students from
Burton-Conner came over and
clipped a little ID badge on
him saying, "Billy." But I
can't imagine, William Rogers,
does not strike me that you
would walk up and call
him Billy Rogers.
I don't know if he had
a nickname or not.
But in any case, Eliot liked--
DAVID KAISER: Mr. Rogers.
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
Mr. Rogers, that would
even be better.
Yeah, Mr. Rogers.
DAVID KAISER: And they called
MIT Mr. Rogers' neighborhood.
PROFESSOR: Well, you're
just full of neat
observations today.
DAVID KAISER: That's
my job, [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's good.
That's good.
You remind me of Waldorf over
and-- you know, the muppets up
in the balcony?
DAVID KAISER: [LAUGHS]
PROFESSOR: You're
Waldorf today.
Anyway, Eliot really liked
what he saw at MIT.
He clearly thinks that MIT
is the core of this "new
education." This is where
the action was at.
And he tried very hard during
his presidential years at
Harvard-- and he was president
of Harvard for at, what, 35
years or so?
A long time.
Never happened.
But that was one of his
fondest wishes.
And he was one of these early
hires that William Barton
Rogers made here.
Clearly, he had sold Eliot
on the MIT vision.
There were others.
Edward Pickering, like Eliot and
Storer, established a very
famous lab in physics here.
And he was literally Rogers
successor as the teacher of
physics at MIT--
again, another Harvard
graduate.
All these early professors are
pretty much Harvard graduates
who came to MIT and then, like
Storer and Eliot, often left
MIT to go back to Harvard,
interestingly.
I don't know exactly why.
Eliot was a very persuasive
person, but I'm sure Harvard
could shake a lot more money in
their faces, too, in terms
of salaries and things
like that.
That's probably important,
an important attraction.
So Pickering, as I recollect,
also returned to Harvard at
one point in this career.
But he was a very important
laboratory builder here at MIT
that established, again, the MIT
model for spreading this
new vision of education
around the country.
And then finally, in
architecture, another Harvard
graduate, William Ware,
establishes the Department of
Architecture at MIT.
It's the first in the country,
and very successful, very much
oriented towards this hands on,
laboratory oriented design
process in architecture.
He was at MIT for
about 15 years.
And then he leaves to go to
Columbia and establish a
similar school at Columbia.
He's considered the leading
educator in architecture of
the late 19th century.
So you have here, in this
early faculty, some very
interesting and significant
people.
And I think the important thing,
for the purposes of our
discussion today, is that
Rogers hired these guys.
He had an eye for talent.
And there's nothing like having
great talent around you
to build a great institution.
And that was underway
by the 1870s.
People were actually writing to
Rogers by the 1870s, like,
within five years of the
founding of this place,
saying, MIT is making
itself heard.
And that reputation continues
to gain momentum throughout
the decades of the late
19th century.
So much so that in the paper
that I wrote, I refer to
Francis Amasa Walker, who was
the third president of MIT
making his annual report in
1894, in which he comes out
and says, basically, thanks
to the founders of this
Institute, and especially to
William Rogers, the battle of
"the new education" " has won.
Well, the new education meant
that MIT had now become the
great model of this new way of
educating people toward a more
integrated curriculum built
around science and
engineering.
That was a new model.
And when you look around the
country today, virtually every
major university has sort of
bought in to that model.
Even a number of small colleges
have, but especially
large state universities--
very much influenced by
this MIT approach.
Now the final point to be made
about Rogers, I think, is that
he's one of the country's
first geologists,
professional geologist.
He's one of the founders
of the field
in the United States.
He is also a founder of the
American Association for the
Advancement of Science.
He's not and he's not on the
inside of that operation, but
he's definitely consulted about
it, is an early member,
and plays a role in it.
But he is an important geologist
in the history of
science in this country.
And he's also an early defender
of Charles Darwin.
Darwin's Origins of Species,
the famous book on
evolutionary theory, was
published in 1859.
And Rogers was one of the first
in the Boston area to
embrace that theory,
and defend it, and
argue that it had--
from his geological perspective
was a viable theory.
He was opposed, very vigorously,
by a zoologist
from Harvard named Louis
Agassiz, who, in more than one
time, tried to do in Rogers,
both as a geologist and as the
founder of MIT.
But, again Rogers had staying
power and was able to make its
way through all these crises.
But I think as a geologist, he
often gets forgotten in that
area, even though he
was an important
contributor to that field.
Now what are the take
home points of the
essay that I wrote.
I'll give you three.
One is obvious.
It's the sustainability of
Rogers' vision for MIT--
the mens et manus theme.
The idea of combining, bringing
together science and
the useful arts.
It's a remarkable continuity,
if you ask me.
I think it's something that has
maintained itself right up
to the present.
That's amazing.
This place is 150 years old, and
yet the founding vision of
the place still informs
it in many ways.
Now that doesn't mean there
haven't been changes.
There surely have been.
And we'll see them
during the term.
But that basic concept has
maintained itself.
That's amazing to me.
Another thing that's important
to note here is the role of
the state in the founding of
MIT, the fact that the state
of Massachusetts, funded by
the federal government,
basically, put up a lot of the
real seed bed money that was
used to get this
place started.
And then that, in turn,
attracted private
donations to MIT.
But as late as the 1890s, MIT
was petitioning the state of
Massachusetts for increments of
$25,000 a year, simply to
try to support the building of
labs and stuff like that.
So Massachusetts have a long
history of involvement with
MIT, even though this was
supposedly a "private
corporation." It's curious.
It's a land grant school that
is a private corporation.
Not many were like that.
Most were state universities
that were state controlled and
did not have this word
corporation.
You might have been a member of
the board of trustees, but
you were not a member
of the corporation
like we have today.
So again the state is
important here.
And then finally, just about
MIT's significance, it's the
new education that's
important.
It's a new breed of cat that's
being developed here, and it's
one that had legs.
It's probably had, I suppose,
this sounds so much like a
homer lecture, but
it is, in a way.
I'm enthusiastic about
the history of MIT.
Maybe it's because I haven't
learned enough about it yet.
But the vision for MIT
had an impact.
It made impacts elsewhere.
It continues to have that.
We'll talk about, later in the
term, about how the MIT model
is now being exported to
Singapore, and to India, and
all over the world.
So it's had enormous,
enormous impact.
And that's not something
to be sneezed at.
And it's really why Charles
Eliot wrote that essay called
"The New Education," was to
point out, this is something
new and different.
This is worth attending to.
And he does a survey of all
these various schools and says
the real place where the
action is is MIT.
That's 1869.
Within months, he was going to
become president of Harvard
and, as I said, made numerous
attempts to try to bring MIT
into the Harvard fold,
unsuccessfully.
So David suggested that's
my remarks, OK.
Brilliant.
Aren't they?
Eli, you thought they were
pretty good, huh?
That's good.
I know all these people.
So you're wondering, why is he
talking to them, you know?
Anyway, David suggested, before
the class started, that
we take a closer look at
Eliot's piece "The New
Education." I debated about
whether we should have you
read this or not because,
frankly, it's pretty boring.
It's not an easy
piece to read.
It's written in a very stilted,
19th century style.
And yet it's says things, if you
can make your way through
it, it does say things,
I think, that are
important to note.
And so, this is basically
Charles Eliot's take on the
state of education, higher
education, in the United
States circa 1869.
That's really what this
essay is about.
And the big distinction he makes
is that he talks about
how there are basically three
different types of higher
education institutions
in the United States.
There are the classical colleges
that teach Latin and
Greek, mathematics, the typical
curriculum aimed at
cultivating an educated
gentleman for society.
That's where gentlemanly
people went.
Ladies, I'm sorry, were not
admitted to those schools in
those days.
Most women, in those days, if
they went to college at all,
and many of them did
not, went to--
my grandmother, who went to one
of these college called
state teachers institutes, or
educational institutes.
But rarely would you see women
on the campus of Yale.
I don't even know
if Yale admitted
women, did they in the--?
DAVID KAISER: 1969.
PROFESSOR: Wow.
See?
It's a good--
OK.
Well, Harvard had Radcliffe.
So they're next door neighbors,
but there's this
divorce that exists.
Now, interestingly, Rogers,
from day one, said we will
admit women to this place.
A very, very small
number came.
And most of those who did come
were called special students.
They were not regular students
like you are but rather
special students who were part
time, basically, part time
students, women who were working
in the area who wanted
to take a chemistry class or
something, could enroll here.
But for it's day, that was quite
a revolutionary and open
minded thing to do, I think.
But he was very open to that.
He was very much a reformer,
I think.
He was involved in the
abolitionist movement.
And David pointed out today that
one of his friends from
Virginia, a guy named Edmund
Ruffin, was actually one of
the first to fire the
Confederate cannons on Fort
Sumter in 1861.
So here's this man coming out
of Virginia who was imbued
with this slave oriented ethos
that's pervaded Virginia prior
to the Civil War, who was open
minded enough to see the
problems and downright evils of
slavery, resist them, and,
eventually, remove himself
from the South
and come to New England.
That's one of the reasons
he moved here.
He was just so sick of the
violent society that Virginia
had become by the 1850s,
especially around slavery.
A lot of his problems came
from that direction.
Well, when Eliot writes about
"The New Education," he
doesn't use that phrase
a lot in here.
You really have to
kind of look--
he may have mentioned the term
new education or some variant
of it maybe three or four times
in the entire essay.
It's not something he's
pounding away at.
But he's making as interesting
comparisons, first, between
these three kinds of
institutions that are trying
to organize educational
framework around the useful
arts and science.
And he argues that two of them
are just abject failures,
basically, there are schools
like the Lawrence School at
Harvard, or the Sheffield
School at Yale, or the
Chandler School at Dartmouth,
that make the attempt but can
never quite achieve what is
needed to be done because
their faculty come from
the school itself.
And as a result, the faculty
loyalties and the degree of
involvement in these new
ways of educating
students is never complete.
It's always sort of
a halfway process.
And that's something that
bothered Eliot a great deal,
especially about Harvard because
the Lawrence School
was heavily endowed
for its day.
And yet it had really had a
sort of a meager record of
turning out students who
were well educated
in the useful arts.
And so that's a problem.
There are other types of
colleges that he talks about
with reference to the useful
arts, smaller schools like
Union College up in Schenectady,
New York or Brown
University down in Providence.
And basically, the argument is
somewhat similar there, is
that it's hard to introduce this
new concept of combining
useful arts and science in
environments that have been
completely oriented toward
the classical education
up until that time.
It's very difficult
to do that.
And as a result, he says, it's
really to the third type of
school, the RPIs, the MITs, are
the two main ones where
this model is more likely
to succeed.
And there, he says that RPI's
been quite successful at it.
It's really the first civilian
engineering school founded in
the United States.
It dates to 1824.
And RPI is basically a place
that trains civil engineers.
It does not get into mechanical
engineering or
metallurgical engineering,
things like that.
It's strictly oriented toward
civil engineering-- by the
time the Civil War,
very successful.
But it's really to MIT
that he looks.
And he says now here is the
model because it's so open to
educating not only civil
engineers but mechanical
engineers, architects,
metallurgical engineers--
MIT has a menu by the late 1860s
that no other school
really has.
And so that is, I think,
a distinctive
comment that he makes.
But basically, I read this,
and for me the takeaway is
that Eliot loves MIT.
He sees MIT as the new direction
for higher education
and that's doing something
different than any other place
has ever done.
It's a good question.
The interesting thing, I wanted
to note, here, though
is that on page 216 near the
end, yeah, he's talking about
RPI and MIT, but he makes no
reference to the US Military
Academy, which is arguably the
first engineering school in
the United States.
It's modeled after the French
Ecole Polytechnique--
except for a footnote at
the bottom of 216.
Did you see this note?
He says the United States Naval
and military academies
are not referred to at length
because-- they're not refer to
at all, basically, because
access to them is not free.
A thoroughly vicious system
blah, blah, blah.
He does not like the
military academies.
But he completely erases
them from the essay.
Did you have your hand up?
AUDIENCE: Um, not really.
PROFESSOR: Huh?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: Oh OK, I thought
you were waving your hand
going, I object!
He's just anti-militarist,
or something.
But those are important
places--
especially West Point.
In fact, I think I say it in my
essay, that the president
of Brown University, Francis
Wayland, made a comment in the
1850s that West Point had
trained more engineers then
all the other colleges in the
United States put together.
Well, that says something.
It's not a big school.
And it also tells you about the
need for more engineers in
the country because West
Point could not produce
all of these people.
Hence the reason why MIT became
so important by the
later decades of the
19th century.
And where did early MIT
graduates go to work?
Many of them went
to railroads.
That was the big industry
after the Civil War.
And many of them go into the
railroad industry as managers,
engineers, railroad builders.
Many go into chemical industries
that are beginning
to emerge during this
period too.
It's interesting, for example,
that the du Pont family sends
the best and brightest of their
family, of young people,
up here to get educated.
Pierre du Pont, one of
the really important
industrialists of the early 20th
century, is a graduate of
MIT class of 1890.
And there were other du Ponts
that came here, too, but he's
probably the most important.
And Arthur D. Little, famous
AD Little Laboratories.
I don't know if they're still,
are they still in operation?
Private research laboratories
in chemistry?
DAVID KAISER: I belive AD Little
is still in operation
but they sold off
the R&D lab--
PROFESSOR: They did, OK.
DAVID KAISER: To an MIT
alum, actually, Kenan
Sahin, owns it now.
And it's got a different name.
PROFESSOR: Oh, he did?
OK.
Well, there's a list of very
eminent engineers, chemists,
applied scientists that are
coming out of MIT by the 1890s
that go on to really play a
big role in the commercial
development and
industrialization of the
United States in the
20th century.
So MIT has had an impact.
I don't know if you want to
say any more about Charles
Eliot's piece here.
DAVID KAISER: I would
read through little
bit of it in detail.
PROFESSOR: Go ahead.
DAVID KAISER: How many people
brought the piece
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Can you get it
off the scholar site?
DAVID KAISER: If you have it,
maybe pull it out because it's
sort of worth, I think, reading
parts of it in some
detail because, first of all,
it's a good exercise in what
we call close reading,
were how you--
I mean, the language
a little foreign.
It's not very foreign, but
what's being said between the
lines, or what's he assuming
that people are saying.
And I think some of it is
relevant to both what
[? Rowe ?] was saying, and
even to MIT today.
I'm sorry?
It is on Stellar, yeah, so
if you have a laptop
you can find it.
You know, he starts out
with this line--
"what can I do with my boy?"
Which is very interesting.
I mean, obviously it's only
boys and men that he's
addressed like [? Rowe ?]
mentioned, that was the
language of the day, up until
a couple of decades ago.
But, sort of addressed to the
parents, and of if you read
down a little bit, this is what
a parent might say, I
want to give my boy practical
education.
One that will prepare him better
than I was prepared to
follow my business, or any
other active calling.
And I like that phrase active
calling, because implied there
is there are passive callings.
I wonder what he means by
a non active calling.
I would guess he would mean the
clergy, or probably law,
and he comes back to
them a little bit.
And then he says this is a
problem that everyone has, but
the difficulty presses more
heavily-- still in the first
paragraph--
on the thoughtful American
than on the European.
And so he's making a distinction
that the
conditions of this country are
special, in some way, for this
kind of education.
It's not the modern phrase of
old Europe, there are special
things here, because the
American is free to choose, in
a way, a way of life for himself
and his children.
And then--
a couple lines down-- in the
face of prodigious material
resources of a vast and new
territory, he is more fully
awake then the European can be
to the gravity and urgency of
the problem.
Also a really interesting way to
start out at the beginning,
that there are special things
about this country.
That's not a new idea, American
exceptionalism, is
what historians call it.
But, the conditions here are
different than in Europe.
Partly because of the huge
size of the place.
amount of resources.
And that makes the American
more fully awake.
And yet, he has fewer options
than any other, except
possibly the English, of
solving the problem.
And then on the next column,
he refers to implicitly
particularly the French
engineering schools.
For more than a generation the
government schools of arts and
trades, arts and manufactures,
bridges and highways--
one of the famous French
engineering school is Ponts Et
Chaussees, the school of
bridges and highways--
Ecole Des Mines--
another famous French
engineering school--
mines, agriculture, and commerce
have introduced
hundreds of well trained
young men.
They begin as subalterns,
basically low people on the
totem pole, but soon become the
commission's officers of
the army, and of industry.
Which is interesting too, what
is the problem that the
European engineering schools
are feeding?
They don't have vast territory
remaining, they don't have
vast resources in their
countries, where are all those
engineers going, if in the US
they're going out west?
Into the colonies.
It's a problem of maintaining
the empire.
He doesn't talk too much about,
he does use the word
empire in there, but in a way
he's sort of arguing that
America has its own empire
right here, and French
particularly, German, English,
they're all building railroads
in the colonies, a little
bit more in
the later 19th century.
PROFESSOR: Think, for example,
the British and India, huge,
huge, and that's only a
part of the British
empire in that period.
It's a huge empire.
DAVID KAISER: Then he this
great line, The American
people are fighting
the wilderness,
physical and moral.
Which is funny, it's also
interesting, this is four
years after the Civil War.
In fact, most of the stuff we've
been reading, relatively
recent, doesn't mention
the war in here.
You have a country that just
lost the better part of a
million people.
The South has been destroyed to
a large degree by the war.
The young people's population
has been destroyed.
I don't know, what was the
population of the US in the
time of the Civil War?
PROFESSOR: I want to say it's
around six million maybe?
DAVID KAISER: So six million,
even if you lost six--
PROFESSOR: I'm not sure.
DAVID KAISER: --hundred thousand
people out of that.
10% of the population.
Extend that out today, that's
like you having a civil war
where you are losing tens
of millions of people.
Nobody would have been
unaffected, and he doesn't
mention it in this piece,
which is also very
interesting.
PROFESSOR: I know one thing,
the South lost 25% of it's
younger men during that war.
25%--
DAVID KAISER: That's huge.
PROFESSOR: --that's a big,
big, [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID KAISER: The American
people are fighting the
wilderness, physical
and moral.
So, you wonder what that,
physical wilderness is
obvious, moral probably is
referring to the, I would
imagine, the Western
wars and--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
DAVID KAISER: --fighting the--
PROFESSOR: Indians.
DAVID KAISER: --Native
Americans there.
And that's his vision
of the battle.
At the same time, trying to work
out the awful problem of
self government.
So he's tying these basic ideas
about education to both
the physical state of the
country, and also the
ideological and government
state of the country.
PROFESSOR: One thing to note
in all that is that William
Tecumseh Sherman was a very
famous Civil War general, he's
the one that burned Atlanta,
and did the famous march to
the sea, was asked during the
1870's, what he thought about
the quote "Indian problem"
Here's this movement west, and
the part of white settlers.
He says, nothing to worry
about, we're building
railroads in the West and that's
driving a stake into
the heart of the American
Indian, or
something like that.
That was going to do them in,
is the engineering of these
new railroad technologies, is
just going to overwhelm them,
and it did basically.
DAVID KAISER: So down in the
bottom of that column he talks
about all these frustrations,
but he knows the greatness of
the material prizes to be won.
So it's not an appeal for moral
elevation necessarily,
or this and that.
It's an appeal for material
prizes, which is very much on
the mind of Americans,
since the founding
On the next page, just
interesting phrases on the top
left, on 204, These old ways
have trained some boys well,
for the life of 50 or 100 years
ago, And the American
will not believe that they are
applicable to his son.
For the reason that the kind of
man which he wants a son to
make, did not exist in all
the world 50 years ago.
This was 1869, and somebody
mentioned in one of their
response papers that they
appreciated, from the reading,
how close the revolution still
was, in that most of the
fathers of these people would
have been directly involved in
it, which is correct.
So, 50 or 100 years ago
there's been all this
political upheaval and America
was a very agrarian society,
but everywhere was, and he's
really referring to what we
now call the Industrial
Revolution there.
Entirely new kind of people
are required.
Then also down in that column,
I think this is very
interesting too, it requires
courage to quit the beaten
paths in which the great
majority of well educated men
have walked, and still walk.
So he's basically saying, and
you even still hear this to
some degree today, the MIT
graduates especially if
they're successful, will enter
a world where everyone knows
Latin and Greek.
Everyone knows different
kinds of history.
Everyone is going to be
extremely well versed in
theology, and these other
things, and MIT graduates, for
the most part, won't be.
But he refers to it as courage
to go into that world with
this new kind of training,
because it will be so rare, it
certainly was rare
at the time.
Frankly, it's still rare, as
you'll find what you graduate.
And that he talks about
a special kind of
courage that's required.
And down at the end or that
paragraph, even more, a boy
who was brought up in a
different way suffers
somewhat, both in youth and
in manhood, from the mere
singularity of his education,
though it may have been better
than the common.
I found that really interesting
to read.
I never thought about this
kind of education as
courageous, or the kind of
people who are educated, as
taking that on.
Because you will be an anomaly,
you may not be if you
go work for a very highly
technical corporation in the
engineering part.
But, most corporations, even
the very highly technical
ones, as you rise up the people
are less and less
engineering educated, not
to mention in the
general social world.
Then he talks a little bit about
the organization that
Roe mentioned on the
next column.
A large number of professors
trained in the existing
methods, hold firm possession
and transmit the traditions
they inherited.
And I just thought that was an
interesting word, inherited.
Because again, he's kind of
trying to overthrow European
model of inheritance, comes back
to that in a minute, and
again the American model
is one of earning it.
And he talks here about how
stodgy these old systems are,
backed by the reputation of
their authors and the capital
of their publishers.
Steadily fed by schools whose
masters are inspired, these
are the older schools, and
all the so-called learned
professions, I love that
kind of language.
Again, I think that's really a
dig at, probably, both the
clergy and the legal
profession, maybe
some others as well.
Also, makes a distinction
between, it's an interesting
thing about, that none of the
MIT founders have any problem
teaching languages.
Which is interesting because one
of the few things that was
required then, that's not
required now, which I'm not
sure is the greatest idea, but
it's the living languages
versus dead languages.
Especially, then if you don't
read French and German, you
can't read engineering
literature basically.
It's not so true today.
German was, for many years, the
real classic engineering
literature.
But just not Latin and Greek.
And then there's a great line on
the top of the 205 where he
talks about, again, the
old style educators.
To have been a school master or
college professor 30 years
ago only too often makes a man
an unsafe witness in matters
of education.
It Is just a great metaphor.
There are flanges on his mental
wheels which will fit
only one gauge.
What is that a reference to?
It's a railroad analogy.
So he's using these sort of
technical analogies to make
his point about the education.
Then he talks here, again, also
sort of a dis at the kind
of great professor model
of education.
In no country is so little
attention paid by parents and
students to the reputation of
teachers for genius and deep
learning as in our
own country.
Faradays, Rumfords,
and Cuviers--
these are the famous European
professors--
would get very few pupils here
if they're teachings were
unmethodical and objectless.
If, in short, they taught under
a bad general system.
Spasmodic and ill-directed
genius cannot compete in the
American community with
methodical, careful, teaching
by less inspired men.
Very interesting argument
to make.
I'm not sure if everyone would
agree with that today
necessarily, but obviously we
don't want to have spasmodic
and ill-directed directed
genius in
front of the classroom.
But, it really is very much
an argument about order in
education and sort of focus
on what's empirical.
And I think that's a really
important component of a lot
of the background here, we
haven't said anything about
the Enlightenment yet,
in this class.
Anybody heard that
phrase before?
Usually associated with the 18th
century, late 17th, most
of the 18th century, into
the early 19th.
But, one of the great focuses
of the Enlightenment is
empirical learning, not just
theorizing, not just the sort
of platonic philosophy of
working as the ancients
through a set of reasoned
arguments, but, actually
gathering data from the world.
Now, what's interesting about
that, is there's sort of a
split that you observe where
if you look at someone like
Louis Agassiz who Roe has
mentioned, the great Harvard
natural history professor at
the time, very much an
enlightenment empiricist, in the
sense of Natural History.
Has anybody been over to
the Harvard Natural
History Museum lately?
What kind of a museum is it?
AUDIENCE: It has
a lot of rocks.
DAVID KAISER: OK,
What else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID KAISER: What?
Animals.
It's a kind of, old-fashioned,
glass case museum.
Right?
Very typical, not what you'd
find, I was just at the
Natural History Museum in New
York, which is used to be that
kind of museum, and still has
pieces of it, but is a very
different kind of museum.
But the Harvard museums are sort
of lovely and wonderful
in this way, but there's cases
and cases of specimens,
whether they're , plants, or
stuffed animals, what's the
correct word?
Taxidermy.
I brought my daughter there
actually, she liked the
stuffed animals.
Animals, plants, geological
specimens, and that's very
much the kind of natural
historical world that Louis
Agassiz represented.
There, the empirical philosophy
was one of
collecting, ordering the
collection, everything's very
carefully labeled.
Very carefully name with a
very fancy Latin name.
Often then numbered, drawers and
drawers, taking the world
classifying it, putting
it into a hierarchy.
You're familiar with the
Linnaean hierarchy of the
natural world.
Very much an enlightenment
practice, but slightly more,
kind of, 18th century version
of it that Agassiz, sort of,
still represents into
the 19th century.
Rogers, in his reaction against
that, is in a way,
kind of even further, more
radical enlightenment.
What's different about the kind
of world that he would
think about?
Let me give you an example that
maybe you could set off.
I was reading last night an
example of a student who said,
when I went to work for
Louis Agassiz at
Harvard as a student.
Basically, he locked me in a
room with 500 tortoise shells
and no supporting anything, and
my job was to discern the
inherent truth of nature that
was collected in those
tortoise shells.
What's the kind of world, the
way that Rogers and an MIT
approach to that problem
might use?
It's also very empirical,
collecting
information from the world.
So it's not that what
he's reacting
against is not empirical.
Well first of all, intervention
by active
experiments.
You're not just collecting the
world and putting it in glass
cases, you're often physically
out in it, collectors were
doing that too, but your making
changes to it, putting
things on, and also enhancing
your senses by using
instruments.
He was a great fan, Rogers, of
new kinds of instrumentation
and the uses of these kinds
of instruments.
They might be spectroscopes,
spectrographs, or obviously
microscopes, but other kinds
of photometers and things.
And a much more kind of, you
might call it high-tech in a
way, but also very active
intervention in the world of
nature, the physical world, the
things you're going into.
It's not a world of collecting
and classifying, and
discerning this inherent
underlying truth from.
It's a world of very active,
and again, as much for the
students as for the researchers
in his world.
Which says something about
why he was such
an admirer of Darwin.
Yeah, very much so.
PROFESSOR: It's a world
that's evolving.
DAVID KAISER: There's a nice
story, which we haven't really
told about, when Rogers finally
gets the charter for
MIT, and the war starts.
And Massachusetts gives him
one year to come up with
$100,000, which is then later
extended to two years and he
almost doesn't make it except
for this big gift from
[? Walker ?].
And so he's figured, OK great,
now I'm off and running, I've
got all this time, the war is
probably going to delay our
plans a minute I can just
go raise money.
And the governor comes back to
him and says, oh, and by the
way, I would really like
you to become the
inspector of gas in Boston.
And gas, at the time, is the
new high tech way to light
your home, and it's a
technological systems, there
are pipes being run under
the streets in the city.
But it's very dangerous,
because as still
today, gas is explosive.
Probably every few months, a
house in the Boston area blows
up because of a gas leak.
And Rogers says, no way,
I can't take the
time out to do this.
This is crazy.
And the governor calls him in
for a one on one, and we don't
really know what was said,
but he walks out of there
convinced that he's
going to do it.
So he takes on this job.
And soon he finds that the
instruments that he's been
given to inspect the gas,
probably the quality of the
gas, and different chemical
composition of it, and the
different illuminating
capabilities, and maybe
measure leaks and things
for safety, are
inadequate for him.
So he re-engineers, and
re-designs a number of the
instruments.
And then he begins to see that
this is actually a very
valuable thing for him because
he uses the states money to
buy the latest instrumentation.
He has very close contact with
industry, and it gives him
insight into what the latest
kinds of instrumentation
should be that the students at
MIT, that he would then buy
for the laboratories as
they're outfitting
laboratories.
And it's a nice little story,
partly because of the kind of
ethos of presidents of MIT doing
national service, or in
that case they service, which is
something we'll talk about
later, starts at
the beginning.
But also because it gets him
out in the world, get him
involved, and he's very much
a fan of instrumentation.
Even though you think about
geology in the 1830's and '40s
is not a ton of instrumentation
associated
with that, although certainly
there is in surveying.
It gives you the sense of him as
not simply a scientist, but
also quite a tinkerer.
A couple other things to point
out in Elliott essay.
I found it interesting because
I actually went to Yale as an
undergrad, and studied
engineering.
So, I could see why he thought
that was all the wrong model,
although he praises
it a little bit.
But, at Yale the school he was
writing about, The Sheffield
Scientific School, which was
a very famous science and
engineering school, doesn't
exist anymore.
It was closed down by the Yale
faculty in the 1950s.
So, it sort of supports his case
that, that kind of model
and The Lawrence Scientific
School doesn't existent at
Harvard either anymore, that
that kind of model is the
wrong model, and not really
destined survive as a second
class citizen there.
But there are a couple other
interesting pieces I
want to point out.
He talks on page 215 about, and
this a good reminder, 216
on the bottom and the left,
he says, when the American
University emerges, it will
not be a copy of foreign
institutions or a
hotbed plant.
But the slow and natural
outgrowth of American social
and political habits.
An expression of the average
aims and ambitions of the
better educated classes.
That's interesting because you
think we've been spending all
of our time you're talking
about the emergence of an
American university, and the
whole issue vis a vis Harvard.
What is he referring to there?
Well, it's worth keeping in
mind that everything we've
been talking about, so far, is
really about college teaching.
Harvard College is still Harvard
College at the time.
I don't know when they changed
their name to Harvard
University.
He says the American college
is an institution without a
parallel, the American
University future tense, will
be equally original.
MIT is not a university then
either, some people think it
isn't today, but I don't think
that's really right.
But what's the difference
between a college and
university?
Simple crude distinction.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
have more colleges.
DAVID KAISER: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Universities have
[? several ?] colleges.
DAVID KAISER: Some
do, not all.
Graduate education.
So that's actually the first,
does anybody know what the
first university is in
the United States?
Johns Hopkins actually.
And it's founded late 19th,
early 20th century.
Where you really have the idea
that there's research and
graduate education, combined
with a college.
So it's just worth keeping
that in mind, as we move
forward in time, and MIT does
become a university.
I mean if you read rankings,
everybody thinks of it as a
university.
There are people here still who
say, no it's a technical
institute, it's not
a university.
I don't think there's really
too much to be argued for
that, but arguably MIT only
really became our university,
in that sense, about
20 years ago.
It's not an old thing.
But the graduate model, the
American University that he is
referring to, is really still
40 years away when he's
writing this in 1869.
Then I just thought there was a
great passage on 218, on the
right column, which also
have an amazing,
and truly MIT metaphor.
People who think vaguely about
the difference between a good
college and a good Polytechnic
school are apt to say, that
the aim of the college course is
to make a rounded man, with
all his faculties impartially
developed.
While it is to express object of
a technical course to make
a one sided man, the mere
engineer, chemist, or architect.
Two truths are supported in
this form of statement.
First, faculties are
not given by God.
Sorry, two truths
are suppressed
in this form statement.
He was arguing against it.
First, faculties are not given
by God impartially, to each
round soul a little
of each power.
As if the soul were a pill,
which must contain it's due
proportion of many variance
ingredients.
To reason about the average
human mind as if it were a
globe, to be expanded
symmetrically from a center
outward, is to be betrayed
by metaphor.
Then I love this.
A cutting tool, a drill, or an
auger would be a juster symbol
of the mind.
If there's not a great
MIT statement, I
think it's that one.
PROFESSOR: That's good.
DAVID KAISER: The natural, best,
and particular quality
of everybody's mind
should be sacredly
regarded in his education.
The division of mental labor,
which is essential in
civilized communities, in order
that knowledge may grow
and society improve, demands
this regard to peculiar
constitution of each mind,
so on and so forth.
But I think, in some way, that's
also a nice statement
of the case for MIT, in
an intellectual sense.
That, not everybody agrees with
it by any stretch, but
that the model of the mind is
the cutting tool, or the
drill, or the auger.
Those of you, all of you, who
are here as undergrads could
probably feel maybe your mind
as being expected to behave
that way on a regular basis,
honed finely and sharpened.
So, I sort of thought
it was worth going
through some of this.
It is a difficult
piece to read.
It's written in this, sort of,
19th century English which can
be hard to read, but it's
actually a very rich piece,
and he's got a very strong
opinions, and some of them I
think are still valuable.
I did exactly what he thought
was a bad idea.
Which was I did both a literary
education and
engineering education
at the same time.
And given that there's only 24
hours a day, it's very hard.
I always my students it's not
hard to do a double major,
it's just twice the work.
Which is sort of true, but
inevitably there are
compromises on either side.
And the question is, what's
the benefit versus what's
lost, I think it probably
depends on the individual and
what you see.
I think in all this
conversation, right, don't
forget that the people who run
this world are still more
Harvard graduates that
MIT graduates.
OK.
There is something about that
model, you go over to Harvard
and you see Teddy Roosevelt,
and Franklin Roosevelt, and
John F Kennedy, and any number
of US presidents who have been
Harvard graduates.
And any number of Harvard
graduates who are in Congress,
and the Senate, and the Supreme
Court, at any given
time, far out way, and even
arguably at the top echelons
of corporations,
MIT graduates.
And it is worth thinking about
why that is, and why it hasn't
been different in the last
150 years, that way.
So what we're reading is the
argument of the people who
founded MIT, and there's
no question that in the
scientific and technological
world MIT graduates have been
great leaders, and actually in
other countries they are more
likely to be found as presidents
or top political
leaders than they are
in this country.
There are many other countries
where engineering is a much
higher prestige profession,
relatively
speaking, than it is here.
And there's reasons for
that, historically.
Even in France, for example,
the polytechnic graduates
really are the people who
populate the upper echelons of
the government.
That may be changing now
in the last 20 years.
But it has not been changing
dramatically.
And so there's a lot of
reasons for that.
And it's a whole other
conversation to have.
But it is interesting to think
about what it really takes to
train people to be leaders and
how well are we doing at that?
Or how well does Eliot's
model do that?
I think the general principle
of it really does go back to
the beginning.
There has always been a fair
amount of English history,
management sort of stuff,
languages, again.
Languages, were considered,
frankly, they probably should
still be considered, a core part
of a technical education.
Because we go around as MIT
saying we're training global
leaders and to do that and not
have a language requirement
for the undergraduates is a
little bit missing the mark.
That's my opinion.
And I'm not someone who's good
with languages at all.
But many colleges have language
requirements, and it
probably would be, as someone
pointed out, more Chinese than
German today.
That's fine.
That's the way the
world is going.
But whatever people
took would surely
benefit them in the world.
But the actual school of
humanities and social sciences
was founded in 1949.
We just celebrated, well just,
10 years ago, we celebrated
the 50th anniversary
of the school.
And the actual eight courses,
I believe, dates from then.
And that was a product, and
we'll come across this, and
we'll read the report that the
so-called Lewis Commission
wrote at the end of World War
II, which really did a lot of
introspection about what kind
of place is MIT becoming.
There's all this military
research, there's all this big
time research on campus.
What do we really owe
our students?
And you all know that you have
eight required HASS courses.
That's quite a bit larger than
most comparable technical
institutions like Caltech
and RPI, Georgia Tech.
It's usually lower.
Certainly overseas at technical
institutions it's
close to zero.
And so it is a much bigger
component of it and arguably
why MIT can consider itself now
among the top ranks of the
universities.
If you asked people at MIT
20 years ago, who are our
competitors?
They'd say Caltech, Georgia
Tech, RPI, The Royal
Institute, ETH in Zurich
and so on.
Now, people will say Harvard,
Yale, Stanford, Princeton.
And that's really only in the
last 20 years that I know as
we compete for undergraduates,
most students who say no to
MIT as undergrads,
where do they go?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Harvard?
DAVID KAISER: No, Stanford is
the place where you lose the
most people to.
So that's a good measure of who
you think you're competing
against when you accept the
student, and they say no,
where are they going?
Far fewer do we lose
to Caltech or
RPI or Georgia Tech.
That's true--
AUDIENCE: Does that also
have to do with
the size of the school?
Like Stanford is a larger
school than Caltech.
DAVID KAISER: It may well.
But Stanford is a very different
place from Caltech.
And so Caltech is a very small
college, as you know.
It's really, still is, in
many ways a college.
Other questions?
Comments from the reading?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] you
mentioned before that
[INAUDIBLE] college
and universities.
So how did graduate education
work for people in the 19th
century here, or how did
it work in Europe?
Was there a lot of advanced
degrees [? conferred?]
in physics or what not?
DAVID KAISER: Well, up into the
1920's, certainly in the
sciences, if you wanted to get a
Ph.D, you went to Germany or
to Europe in general, England,
France as well.
And so if you look at the MIT
faculty in the sciences in the
teens and '20s, most of them
would probably have European
educations at the
graduate level.
That was not just because of
what programs were available
but also because
of the quality.
It was really the German
universities in physics that
were the main thing.
That begin to change during
the decades before the
second World War.
Not least when a lot of European
professors came here.
But PhDs in engineering, I mean
you don't even see them--
MIT did not--
I know Vannevar Bush, who
graduated with a Ph.D in 1916,
I believe, that was MIT's fifth
Ph.D in engineering.
So a 20th century phenomena
to be sure.
And, again, engineering was
considered a useful art.
A Ph.D was considered a high,
scholarly calling.
And there was a lot of ferment
in and around I want to say
1890 to 1905 or so.
University of Chicago
was big in that.
They hired--
it was in Worcester, Clark
University used to have all
these famous people.
Robert Goddard was there
for a while and so on.
And now it's sort of a little
university in a way.
Why?
Because the University of
Chicago came in with a lot of
money and hired away all their
people around 1910, I believe.
So it's very much a 20th
century thing.
PROFESSOR: I was thinking about
Warren Lewis who is the
author of the report David
referred to that established
the humanities requirement
at MIT.
He was a chemical engineer.
And he joined the MIT faculty
around 1910, 1911 after doing
his Ph.D in Germany.
And so he's right at the
borderline, I think.
And he's very much responsible,
in a way, for not
just revolutionizing
undergraduate education after
World War II but also being
involved in the establishment
of doctoral programs at MIT.
After the arrival of Karl
Compton which is 1930 that--
Compton is a physicist who came
to MIT from Princeton and
comes out of a background at
which doctoral education is
important to him.
And so he supports that.
And then it really grows, I
think, during his presidency
and then beyond.
But Lewis is a really
interesting person.
To think that here's a chemical
engineer who is
talking so strongly about the
need for humanities education
at a technical university,
basically, or a technical
institute is very interesting.
His granddaughter is a
colleague of ours.
And I think she's coming to
give a talk about him.
He's extremely interesting, he's
one of these key people
at MIT in the 20th century
that had his
hand on a lot of things.
DAVID KAISER: You would not find
MIT faculty mostly having
PhDs until probably
also about 1920.
Arthur Kennelly is either the
first or one of the first
electrical engineering
professors here and really
kind of founds the department.
He was Bush's advisor.
Where did he come from?
He worked in Thomas
Edison's lab.
I don't believe he had a Ph.D.
And Edison really started this
model of industrial research
around the 1890s.
And that was what brought
people back in.
PROFESSOR: Is that it begins to
happen after World War II
mainly because so much
important research
was going on here.
And big laboratories were
established after World War II
or during and after World War
II that would have enhanced
graduate education.
And as a result, when
you're educating the
best, you hire them.
I think that's how it happened,
especially in the
School of Engineering which has
had a fairly long track
record of hiring its own.
If you're producing the best,
you try to hire the best.
And so I would guess, it's
a guess, I don't have the
answer, but I would guess that
it's right after World War II
that you begin to see it.
DAVID KAISER: So I would give
you a different answer.
I would guess that
it was earlier.
Because, again, if you read
all the stuff like in
Elliott's piece about why the
institution not only needs to
be what it is, but it needs
to be autonomous.
I often think of it as a kind
of sign of MIT's arrogance
like nobody else in the
world is good enough.
So we have to hire
our own students.
But you read this sort of stuff,
and you see it's part
of the culture in that when
they're on the cutting edge of
either a field or just generally
of the types of
teaching that you're doing then
you really, it's very
hard to find people from
elsewhere who are doing that.
PROFESSOR: So, you would say
it's during the Compton years
starting in the '30s
or there abouts?
Or even before that?
DAVID KAISER: I would imagine
it's before that with hiring
instructors.
Not sure about that.
PROFESSOR: That's interesting.
DAVID KAISER: Obviously,
it's not so early on.
But I bet as soon as they become
the right age, it's
something that gets done.
It can't be something that's
done that often without some
traditions behind it.
A lot of universities
won't do it at all.
Although, here, I was talking to
someone in Economics, they
won't hire their own graduates
on the faculty until they've
gone away for a year or
two, and then they
will hire them back.
So, they have a rule that you
cannot come out of your Ph.D
and join the faculty.
But you go somewhere else for
a little while and then you
can come right back.
And many of their faculty
have PhDs from here.
PROFESSOR: Not a bad rule.
Not to my knowledge.
I don't think there is
a big difference.
It's basically a play on the
same word, technic but
preceded by poly means many.
Basically, it's perhaps
a reference to a
more diverse approach.
I don't know.
You're asking good questions.
I don't have the answers.
DAVID KAISER: I think it's
just what you said.
I think polytechnic, especially
at this time, has a
little more European
connotation.
The French schools really are,
they are called polytechnique.
And they have a certain
way of being that.
West Point was modeled after
much of, but probably not so
all of, in that they're
very connected in
the political system.
And there's a very sort of well
understood hierarchy for
the alumni to go through and run
the big bureaucracies and
the government.
And there are polytechnic
schools in this country.
There's California Polytechnic,
there's Brooklyn
Polytechnic.
And I think it's really
those are not--
there's no meaningful
distinction from them from MIT
or Caltech.
It's a kind of term,
connotation.
PROFESSOR: The other thing
that's relevant to that is
that Rogers, Charles Eliot,
William Ware in architecture
all spent time in Europe,
especially in France during
the founding years of MIT, late
'60s early '70s, looking
at European universities and, to
a degree, German technical
institutes.
And so they're influenced by
these European organizational
models, if you want
to call it that.
They don't copy them directly.
But they surely are looking
and trying to find niches
where certain parts of the
French educational system fit
in to the MIT model and
stuff like that.
They're borrowing.
They're definitely borrowing
ideas as they should.
And so those influences are
very much in evidence
especially during
the early years.
DAVID KAISER: It's worth
mentioning a phrase that may
come up which is technocrat.
Has anybody ever heard
that phrase?
PROFESSOR: Technocrat.
DAVID KAISER: You'll hear it
used from time to time.
And, again, technocracy is a
sort of funny social movement
from the '20s.
It's not quite worth
talking about.
But people do talk about
technocrats when they're
technically trained people who
are in high positions of
bureaucracies of one kind or
another and bring a sort of
technical mentality to running
a large organization.
And, again, in France, the
technocratic tradition is a
very old tradition where the
leaders of the polytechnic go
into the UN, they go into the
various civil bureaucracies,
and it's the big government
institutions are very much run
by people with technical
backgrounds.
It's just not a tradition
in the US that has
been nearly so much.
And so we'll come across it when
we talk about the '60s
like Robert McNamara who ran
the Pentagon during the
Vietnam War is not an MIT
graduate, he's not an engineer.
But he was a very technical
person, very mathematical.
He was a sort of prototype
technocrat.
But most leaders of the Pentagon
are not technical,
most of them are political in
background and have very
different kinds of skills and
approaches to the world.
Robert Seamans, who we'll talk
about as well, who was an MIT
graduate and kind of led the
chief engineer on the Apollo
program and Secretary of the
Air Force and the first
Secretary of the Energy was
much more in a kind of
technocratic role where he had
this kind of background.
And so you'll see some of
it in the US setting
but not that much.
Whereas, again, the
polytechniques and the English
system doesn't really work
that way either.
They have their own civil
service system and engineers
are not particularly high up.
PROFESSOR: Seamans is one of
these MIT trained engineers,
comes from an old New England
family as I understand it, but
who really reached in
the higher echelon.
He wasn't a politician, but he
ran a number of agencies and
really was a person of
considerable influence.
He's only been dead, what?
Three years, four years?
DAVID KAISER: One or two.
Has anyone heard that name?
Robert Seamans?
PROFESSOR: Robert
Seamans, aero?
DAVID KAISER: We'll
come across him.
PROFESSOR: I'm so sorry he's
not still alive to come and
visit this class because
he was quite--
DAVID KAISER: He's an
interesting story.
You know we haven't also
mentioned huge issue of social
class between Harvard and MIT.
And all of this stuff that we're
reading has buried in it
the sort of MIT attitude that
Harvard is for elites, and the
Harvard attitude that MIT
is for vocational
middle class workers.
And that runs throughout
all this history.
And Seamans came from this very
old New England family,
comes from a family on
the North Shore.
And he went to Harvard as an
undergrad, in fact he was
classmates with John
F. Kennedy.
And I think he maybe took one
course, or he had a friend who
was doing something at MIT,
and he got really
interested in MIT.
And he wanted to come here
for graduate school.
And he writes in his memoirs
about how his parents said,
no, no, no, fine boys from our
background don't go to MIT,
that's not what they do.
Go, study science at Harvard.
And he rebelled against that and
really said, no I really
want to go to MIT.
And he did amazingly
well here.
But when time came for him to
advance in his career, he was
certainly helped by the fact
that he had this advanced
social background when he
went back to Washington.
And, again, he was rubbing
elbows with JFK and all the
senior leadership during
that period.
And he was socially very
well suited for it.
So he was a little
bit unusual as an
engineer during that period.
PROFESSOR: About every 20 years,
there's a discussion
that pops up in the MIT
community about why doesn't
MIT have as many CEOs as Harvard
or Princeton or--
and a lot of it centers around
what David has just said is
that if you look at the social
backgrounds of CEO's, the
majority of them come out of
backgrounds like Seamans.
They come out of well-to-do,
socially placed families.
And so there's this generational
movement that you
went to Harvard, and you're from
an old family, and you
have an interest in the company,
you become the CEO at
some point.
I think there's a lot
of truth to that.
And MIT, I think, has been
more of a place that has
attracted socially mobile
students from middle class
backgrounds, sometimes working
class backgrounds,
oftentimes, I think.
And which is one of the great
things about the place, I
think, is that--
DAVID KAISER: The fraction of
our students who are the first
generation of their family
to go to college, even
today, is very high.
A lot of children
of immigrants--
PROFESSOR: I think there's a
very old cultural influence
involved in all of this in the
sense that during the 19th
century when we're talking about
the founding of MIT, one
of the tensions of that period
in the academic world was
between what groups we'll call
Ancients versus Moderns.
And the Moderns would be the
type of school like MIT that
was emphasizing science and
engineering as opposed to the
Ancients, which were the old
classical colleges teaching
Greek and Latin and all the
classics and literature and
things like that.
There was a lot of
tension there.
And it also had class
implications that you were
educating people on the classics
to be gentlemen and
ladies and things like that.
Whereas people coming to the
MIT were people that were
going to go out in the world
and engineer that world or
pursue science in that world.
It was a much more utilitarian
oriented disposition, I think,
which is very American in
many ways because early
sociologists, I guess you could
call them, people like
Alexis de Tocqueville, who
visited the United States in
the 1830's and wrote a very
famous treatise called
Democracy in America, asks a
lot of questions about what
makes the United States
what it is.
Why is it different
from Europe?
That's one interesting questions
he's asking.
One of the answers he gives is
that these Americans are so
utilitarian oriented.
They are very oriented towards
things that work, things that
are put to work in society.
Where as you don't see as
much of that in Europe.
That was one of his most
important statements about the
difference between Europe and
the United States, is
Americans like utility.
They like things that work.
They like to get out and tinker
around with stuff.
He also talks about literacy
in the United States being
higher than it is in Europe.
And that being a more literate
nation meant that the United
States was more apt to be
inventive and pursue areas of
engineering and science
that others would be
less involved with.
DAVID KAISER: It arguably is.
Which I'm not so
sure, German--
PROFESSOR: Maybe.
DAVID KAISER: I'm not so sure.
Where it is also is very much
in developing countries even
in the Middle East and lots of
places where MIT has had an
influence actually setting
up engineering schools.
But I'll give you one example,
a lot of wealthy American
families, they send their
brightest kid to Harvard and
may become a lawyer or other
place and become a lawyer.
I used to spend a lot
of time in Turkey.
And I worked with some people
who were very wealthy and ran
a lot of big international
trading which is an old
Turkish kind of profession.
And these were the very
few, very elite
families in that country.
And the people who were my age
who were really the ones
running and soon to inherit
the business, they had all
gone to American engineering
schools and
gotten American MBA's.
That was their education.
And I was once at a conference,
and I sat next to
a guy who was a deputy oil
minister from Iran, which I
don't meet a lot of
Iranian government
officials in my work.
And I was sort of like, this
will be an interesting
conversation with the two of
us are going to talk about.
And he was like, you're
from MIT?
I went to the Iranian Institute
of Technology, it
was all founded on
MIT's principles.
And he was incredibly pleased
to meet someone from MIT.
And sort of like a lot of the
Iranian technocratic class, as
it were, were trained
as engineers.
And, again, it has a lot to do
with when countries got on the
steep part of the development
curve.
And if it was after World War
II, engineering is generally a
pretty high status thing
in the field.
If they're older countries, it's
going to be less so and
more political or financially
oriented.
That's a broad generalization,
but it's probably not that--
PROFESSOR: It's interesting.
DAVID KAISER: I have one story
that maybe we should end with
which was, I went to Yale as an
undergraduate, and I was a
middle class kid.
And I remember going
to graduation--
has anybody here been
to one of the MIT
commencements, by the way?
You'll all go in
a couple years.
PROFESSOR: I hope you do.
DAVID KAISER: Hopefully,
you'll all go.
So when I graduated from Yale,
it was a beautiful May day,
and it had the feeling of
sort of a garden party.
Everybody was incredibly well
dressed and sort of very
polite and well behaved
with the big hats on.
And you had the sense that these
families had been to
Yale graduations many
times in the past.
And it was very sort
of contained.
And the clapping was
sort of like this.
When you go as faculty or as
students too to an MIT
graduation, you march down
Memorial Drive in all the
regalia, and there's somebody
in the front with the
processional.
And you don't really see any of
the parents or any of the
audience until you turn off
of Memorial Drive into the
Killian Court, right in
the center there.
And it has this feeling,
you feel like
you're at a rock show.
I mean the parents are
just over the top.
And there's hundreds of them
outside the gate because they
only get two tickets per grad,
but they bring like 15 people
and cousins and aunts and uncles
and grandparents and
everything.
And you really have the sense
that it's like a huge
celebration.
And, to me, that always
represents that kind of
different social standing where
it's a really big deal
for families when their kids
graduate from MIT whether
they're immigrants
or not because--
but it sort of represents
something.
Sometimes that's a pressure that
the students carry, which
is not so easy.
But it really represents
something.
And it's a big celebration.
It's not nearly as much
something that generations of
Smiths have done for all these
years, and it's been expected,
and we're so proud of
you, kind of thing.
And you'll see when
you graduate, it
really feels that way.
There's 10,000 people there.
And they're just sort of like
coming out of the woodwork and
climbing up the trees
and everything.
And it's a very--
to me that's the kind of
ultimate MIT moment where--
it's nice as a faculty member,
you remember like what we were
working for all these years and
I'm sure students as well.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's a good
time, you'll enjoy it.
Alex will go up to get his
diploma, or whoever, and
you'll hear people
shouting from the
audience, that's my Alex.
And then other students are
going, ah Alex, way to go,
blah, blah.
It's all very exciting.
DAVID KAISER: And they read
every single name of the 2,000
or so people who graduate,
which itself is quite an
accomplishment of logistics
to make that work.
PROFESSOR: You'll have your
hand shaken either by the
President of the Provost.
Isn't that they hand
out every degree?
So, it's pretty cool.
When I went to Ohio State, there
were like, I don't know,
5,000 people on the
football stadium.
They are all down on the field
and the President gets up, and
said, I hereby declare
you Bachelor of Art.
Boom.
And that was done.
And everybody goes, OK, let's
get the hell out of here.
It's very, very different.